we're the lone Pines site or something
it's one of the few places in the la
vicinity that has tall trees no
underbrush coming out of that bridge
sequence and tie-fighter just blew up
we're starting further out so we can see
the patch of trees come in to this more
sparse area so we can do some faster
like dodging and like tailing each other
which then somehow would then lead into
going through this have a look above it
we might be able to find a spot to dive
in yeah breeze from above over here and
just dive straight in exactly one I
think found it left behind you watch out
for that other tree there's a Park
branch there that twigs leg about to hit
you there if you hit that park bench
you're in trouble I wouldn't hit that
going a really long way away that's how
you do it I'm gonna go check it real
quick uh you also lost the bolt oh ask
the bolt too said if we make a sequel to
this we'll call it drone Star Wars
Strikes Back would it be John Star Wars
strength neck well it strikes like huh
which owns Star Wars strikes back
don't Star Wars what strikes back
screwdriver there's another crash for
you now on to the bolt
back out again
dang so are you guys gonna watch all the
footage tonight so Dee and Nico are
really good at archery and in the
comments my feelings were a little hurt
cuz no one expected me to be any good
and I'm not great but I might give them
a run for their money in the contest in
a few arrows never actually strung a bow
before let's see if you [ __ ] it up hold
on
there's no way I'm doing this right - no
singing book there right see you might
be upside down together is that like it
no come on Wren no come on man
you'd imagine we're in an ancient war
and we're standing next to each other as
archers in battle brothers in arms we're
gonna die and after he finishes up with
us it's gonna get Obie
we're gonna take him out all right you
know what they eat dog I hate dog once
well that's for another time
Oh
ja ja cheat the bullseye okay Sam how
you feelin
yeah least I'm not sitting in an office
we parked way up over the top of that
Ridge up there it was already fortified
it was considering there wasn't the
trail oh we made one scene that's that's
the thing we're trailblazers here at
corridor digital both on the internet
and in private property these blazes all
the way all right so we're about to
launch the drones we're on the edge of a
cliff they're gonna stand with their
eyes closed
right Sam we had been bushwhacking our
way at the side of this mountain there's
no trail after climbing from right there
and now we hiked back down half way down
the other side of the mountain to
retrieve the tripod and the red dragon
and we got it I said now we gotta climb
back up carrying this 25 pound tripod
and most importantly the goldfish was so
insane especially like the first time
they started flying I was standing up I
literally was like this like on the
cliff missile so I just like put my butt
down on the dirt and it's just like all
right there we go basically we were
flying off the edge of a cliff yesterday
and we all had fpv goggles on I'm
surprised that no one's slipped and hurt
themselves actually rentoid slipped and
hurt himself i'm going to attempt to
fire two arrows at once well both of
them hit the bull's eye or just one boom
oh my god both ears hit the lost are you
kidding me at wofe had to go man sunday
there's not going to be a salmon
nicovideo
why because carmichael has a lot of work
to do between now and Monday and as a
whole big behind the scenes for Star
Wars because it's a good
behind-the-scenes and it's gonna take a
lot of work for Monday so we have a vlog
coming out tomorrow which is probably
what you're watching right now and then
rather than a new vlog coming out Sunday
we're going to skip 2 days and have a
vlog come out Monday and then maybe a
vlog Tuesday so we'll make up for it
also the Sowers videos coming that's
pretty neat but trust me Monday it's
going to be really good Carmichael will
hopefully get to spend some time at home
this weekend I won't be because the the
game plan before telling me that I also
have to color and pop those sound
designing the plan was to spend three
hours Sunday when
is done with pictures that way I can
lock the sound they'll take me about
three hours so now that the color and we
don't want to spend another four hours
it's no longer on your plate sound in
Monday's video sound you help with
Monday's video and crossbows video and
until you will be like Captain Planet if
there's only two planeteers gonna take
pollution down to zero